okay I'm gonna try and keep this brief
but I did want to make a quick video and
show how to ask me questions because
I've been getting a lot of questions
across all platforms imaginable lately
and YouTube comments me chassé via email
and I'm actually thinking about starting
some kind of YouTube video series where
I go over user questions perhaps
something called like ask Eric or ask I
am Rosen so stay tuned for that but I
want to show probably the the best best
practice when it comes to sending your
questions or sending me a game or
sending me a variation that you're
wondering about because someone asked me
a question today gave me a line where is
typed out but the notation didn't make
any sense so I just want to show
probably the best practice and in
sending something that's annotated and
something I can very easily understand
so it will be done through Lee chess if
you go to lead me chess org go to learn
go to study it's helpful if you have an
account and just go ahead make a new
study and this will bring you to the
study creation page you can name it
whatever you want we can name it
maybe Eric Rosen's oops I did not want
to do that but we can rename it
afterwards I just pressed and pressed
enter by mistake but okay let's make
let's make a new chapter now question
and most people have questions about
openings just naturally so it's
completely fine to just start with
initial position if you have a question
about a specific position or you want to
ask about specific game and you have PGN
you can use some of the other options
too to load in something but we'll start
with in the show position select create
chapter and here you can just enter your
moves
now if we wanted to rename the study
I'll just call this Eric Rosen's
question and someone asked me a question
today which I'll probably go over in one
of in a very very soon to be created
video but someone was asking about the
London what to do after this line where
black plays in kind of early Queen b6 so
let's say knight c6 III Queen b6 and
saying that this is just a good
variation for black and what to do for
whites so let's say you wanted to make a
comment in this in this position this is
an annoying line how should I deal with
this as white me chess is great where
you can basically annotate on any given
move so here we see I made a comment
after Queen b6 we could include some sub
variations if you has another question
and you want to you know what to doing
and c5 what should I play against this
of course this is all just for for
example but these are questions that
people have asked me before so once you
create a study you can also add new
chapters like if you had multiple
questions and you wanted to separate
them into chapters we could add a new
chapter and say question about something
else and I should note that if you ever
want to change the study setting
settings and let's say you didn't want
it public but you wanted it to be
unlisted or invite-only you could change
that and you have a bunch of options
here which are pretty self-explanatory
but then let's say you want to share the
question with me it's very simple all
you have to do is just grab the link
which is I believe slightly out of frame
maybe I can move it into frame if you
see this link right here you can just
highlight that and do just you control-c
or command-c and then paste it to me and
a message
you can message me on me chess that's
probably the easiest way and I do want
to say I've been bogged down with
messages lately so I have not been able
to answer everyone's questions that have
have sent me one but this is one of the
reasons why I'm hopefully going to start
a video series just answering questions
hopefully brings some some more
instructive value to the audience so I
think that will be that I'll leave links
in the video description of how to very
quickly access a velvet chess study page
is just Lee chest org slash study which
will bring you to this page and then
I'll I'll leave you a link to of how to
to message me if you just go to my
profile and then you can there should be
a message button here when you when you
go to my profile and hopefully that will
that will lead to some interesting
questions that I can answer in future
videos so with that stay tuned and I
will see you guys in the future